>>Ankur: Hello.
Welcome everyone to another APAC Developer
Office Hours.
So for those of you guys that are joining
us for the first time, this is your opportunity
to join us live and ask us questions on Android
development.
You also have the opportunity to post questions
on Google moderator.
So if you go to the plus Android developers
Google plus page, you will see this particular
event.
And you will be able to go follow the link
to developers.google.com slash live.
You'll see our event there.
And there's a moderator page at the bottom
of that event page.
So you can post some questions.
And we answer them live.
So let me introduce our team for today.
Firstly, we have Anirudh Dewani from Hyderabad.
>>Anirudh: Hi Guys.
>>Ankur: Then we have Tony Chen joining us
from Hong Kong.
>>Tony: Hello everyone.
>>Ankur: And I am Ankur Kotwal and I am joining
in from Sidney, Australia.
So, unfortunately we weren't able to run a
Hangout last week.
So there was a bit of a gap.
But I'm really glad you could join us today.
And we can resume normal scheduling.
So, we've got a number of questions that have
been posted to the Google moderator page.
And we're just gonna go through them one by
one.
Let us try and do something a little bit tricky
and share our page.
The moderator page.
Let's see if we can get that to happen.
And so let me go to screen share.
And Android APAC Office Hours.
>>Tony: Cool.
I can see that.
>>Ankur: Excellent.
Good start.
So.
Wow.
This is last week's one.
So that's a little bit embarrassing.
Let me flick to this week's one.
And do the screen share again.
Apologies for that.
Alright.
So here we are.
Uh, let's just go through these one by one.
First one is from Ryan from Edmonton.
Tony would you like to take this one?
>>Tony: Yeah, sure.
So "What is the best practice recommended
method for implementing push notification
in an enterprise app specifically?"
So we have something called C2DM.
And now we are officially launched it in Google
IO.
What we now call Google cloud messaging.
So it's really a reliable way to do push notifications.
So we have documentation on our website.
And I think if you Google "GCM" or Google
"Cloud messaging" you should be able to find
the documentation.
>>Ankur: Cool. [pause]
>>Tony: Uh, do we have Ankur?
>> Anirudh: I think we've lost Ankur.
>>Tony: OK, so.
Um, I guess Anirudh you can take the second
question before, um.
OK, I think—
>>Anirudh: I think Ankur is back.
>>Tony: Ankur is back.
>>Ankur: Yeah, my apologies for that.
I actually don't know what happened.
But I'm back.
So.
Next question.
"My question last week was not about the IO
2012 app but the issues on the spinner.
The app is an example showing us that it is
not working and with source code provided
to us.
May I have a follow up this week?"
So just some context about that.
Last week we had, uh, we had a question about
using the spinner in the action bar.
So you know, the content control.
And [video cuts out] with the ViewPager.
Hi there Andrew.
>>Andrew: Hey, how's it going?
>>Tony: Hi.
>>Ankur: Good thank you.
So you formerly had raised some questions
about basically saying, when I use my spinner,
the spinner dropdown will change pages.
But when I actually swipe across pages, it
doesn't update the spinner for me.
So Anirudh, do you wanna take this one?
>>Anirudh: Yeah, so I think the ViewPager
is not wired up to spinner.
So that the ViewPager events have problems
getting back to spinner.
So there's one thing you can do, is you can
try updating, so when you swipe and move to
a certain fragment, you can try updating the
item from the spinner adapter.
Which is basically what's backing up the spinner.
You can try updating that fragment from the
spinner adapter.
The position of the fragment.
And then manually call spinner.set selection.
and provide that position to the spinner.
So I think that should change up the spinner
view.
But you may want to check if they went this,
again, flying back and tries to again, you
know, switch to that fragment.
In that case you can write and say "Hey, it's
a swipe so don't really change the fragment."
>>Ankur: Fair enough.
Thank you.
Hey, Andrew, so we, since you're here live,
did you have any questions for us before we
move on to another one?
>>Andrew: Eh,not today, no.
Just kind of listening in today.
>>Ankur: OK, no worries.
I'll just screen, share again the set of questions.
So, Abhi had also asked us some questions
last week.
And we didn't have the answers available for
him live at the time.
So I asked him afterwards to post them on
the moderator.
So that we could answer them in the next Office
Hours.
So let's look at his question.
He said, "Firstly, thanks for the follow up
on this.
I had two questions.
What is the optimal way to get the existing
fragment from ViewPager."
That's question number one.
And question number two is, "What is the difference
between ViewAnimator and ViewFlipper?"
OK.
So first question.
What's the optimum way to get the existing
fragment from the ViewPager?
The ViewPager can actually give you, you can
get the ID of your fragment from the ViewPager.
That's the one that's currently being displayed.
And then you can use your fragment manager
to basically go and pull that fragment itself.
Now, remember Abhi had also had some questions
around, well if I've already instantiated
a bunch of fragments, how do I ask the ViewPager
to go return me those fragments?
Now you have to be a little bit careful here.
Because the way the ViewPager works is that
it actually will instantiate those fragments
when it needs to.
And it'll keep bits and pieces of them around.
Depending on whether you're using a fragment
page adapter or a fragment state page adapter.
So there's two ways you can actually try and
fetch you know, these fragments that are being
pre-instantiated.
The first is that when you instantiate the
fragment, add it to your fragment manager
using a tag.
You know.
Give it a name. and then you later on, you
can query the fragment manager to go return
that particular fragment.
The other way you can do it is that when you
instantiate your fragments, you can track
it in your own array or vector.
Or map.
Yourself.
And hold on to it there.
So when you need to go and fetch it, you can
go and return the one that's already been
instantiated.
So that's question one.
Question two is, "What is the difference between
the ViewFlipper and the ViewAnimator?"
Well, the ViewAnimator is actually the base
class for the ViewFlipper.
So the ViewFlipper is a specialized version
of the ViewAnimator.
And it's really there so that you can have
a set of views that you can really go from
one to the next to the next.
And have some sort of animation playing.
So the ViewAnimator allows you to specify
things like which particular animation you
want to use when you transition from one view
to the next.
ViewFlipper itself actually specializes in
the sense that the main thing that it can
do is that you can actually say "Hey, I want
a specific time interval.
Go to the next view automatically."
So you could say maybe every five seconds,
it might be a photo gallery app.
Right?
So you might be wanting to show a slide show.
So you can say every five seconds, go to the
next view.
So you know, the view flipper just kind of
provides some of that nice stuff for you in
terms of the timing.
Before we just wrap that question up, there
is actually something called a ViewSwitcher
as well.
The ViewSwitcher also has a base class in
ViewAnimator.
The ViewSwitcher is special in that it only
supports two views.
Whereas the ViewFlipper supports two or more.
Now the reason you might use a ViewSwitcher
is literally when you're just toggling back
and forth between those two views.
But the ViewSwitcher also allows you to specify
your own view factory.
So by doing that you can choose how you instantiate
it, and use a factory pattern to implement
it that way.
Alright.
Thanks for the question Abhi.
Just switch back to the questions and we have
Jack.
"When will Google revise the API for serving
Maps on fragments?
Right now we have to resort to workarounds
using MapActivity and this makes the code
ugly."
To be honest, this is a question that's incredibly
popular.
We get it all the time.
We don't have anything to announce but it's
something that we, the engineering team is
certainly looking at.
But there's just, there's no announcements
around this.
So right now you are stuck with using the
MapActivity.
OK.
Ah. [pause]
Next question.
From Vimal.
"What is the optimal way for adding multiple
fragments under a single tab in the tab view
with back track functionality on the back
button?
Right now I am facing an issue with the back
button when there are two fragments loaded
under single tab for two tabs."
Hmm.
OK.
So I'm trying to make sense of this.
Tony, do you?
Tony or Anirudh?
Do you guys wanna chime in on this one at
all?
>>Tony: Well, one thing about the back button
is for sure you need to add when you add those
new fragments you need to have them put into
a transaction.
So that when the user hits the back button,
it will roll back all the changes.
That I think, if that's, if that's been Vimal's
question.
So, anything to add to that?
>>Anirudh: Uh, I didn't quite get the last
statement of the question either.
>>Tony: Yeah.
>>Anirudh: So, I mean you have APIs available
of how to backstack to how you wanna manage.
And only that something that goes through
a comment will actually go into the backstack.
So you can press back on that.
To go to the previous [unintelligible].
>>Ankur: Yeah.
And there's also overrides that you can implement
in your activity to say, on back button pressed
as well.
So if you wanna specialize even further.
Just keep in mind that that override came
in to API ten, I wanna say.
But it might have been a different API version.
So, but certainly add to backstackers there.
The only other thing that I'll add is that
we've made this a little bit nicer in Jellybean.
You can now specify backstack navigation behavior
through XML.
So in your layout files you can actually,
there's an XML attribute where you can say,
that basically what you're saying is when
you're on this particular element and you
hit back, which one should it go to?
Which view should it go back to?
OK.
Um, back to the questions.
Um, alright.
"How do I make my hardware device," and they
said HTC, "available for testing instead of
using the emulator, without sending my app
to the Android market?"
And I guess this person means the PlayStore
now.
Tony, do you wanna grab this one?
>>Tony: Yeah, sure.
So in general you can do testing development,
using Eclipse.
And using the ATT plug-in.
So for testing using a real phone, you need
to enable USB debugging on your phone.
I wonder whether people can see this or not?
>>Ankur: Yeah, we can see that.
>>Tony: Yes, it's under setting so um, there
is a option called "enable USB debugging."
So once you enable that, you just plug your
phone through USB to your laptop or desktop.
One thing about window involvement, you may
need to install a driver.
For that.
And, other than that, you can just use Eclipse
hooking USB debug through your real phone.
So.
>>Ankur: Cool.
Thanks Tony.
Alright.
The next question is from Abhi again.
And I intentionally didn't cover in my previous
answer to him, cover a particular topic.
Because I was waiting for this question.
And it's basically, "What's the difference
between the FragmentPagerAdapter and the FragmentStatePagerAdapter?
And also when should either of them be used?"
So basically what it is is that the FragmentPagerAdapter,
when the fragments are no longer required,
what it will do is relinquish the view hierarchy
for that fragment.
But it'll keep the fragment around.
In the case of the FragmentStatePagerAdapter,
what it will do is actually call "save state"
on the fragment and it will release the fragment
itself.
So when the fragment, again, needs to be re-instantiated,
what it will do is restore the state that
it saved earlier.
Now, that's a reasonably subtle difference.
But basically what it is, it's about, it's
a trade-off between performance versus memory
requirements.
Memory usage, sorry.
So, a fragment pager adapter, because it only
relinquishes the view hierarchy, it stays
resident in your app.
So it's obviously consuming more memory.
But it means that when that fragment is required
again, it has to do less work to go and show
that fragment.
So that's one that performs slightly better.
But because it consumes more memory, it's
less scalable.
And that's where the FragmentStatePagerAdapter
comes in.
Where if you have lots and lots of fragments,
you're better off using the StatePagerAdapter
which is going to be more aggressive about
relinquishing memory.
So it's a bit of a trade-off.
See how many fragments you're expecting to
have in your app.
I wouldn't even say that there's a magic number.
But have a look at it.
I can say if you've got more than a handful
of fragments that you're displaying then move
to the StatePagerAdapter.
Otherwise stick with just the FragmentPagerAdapter.
OK.
Next question.
Uh, "Considering I've been living under a
rock for the past six years," Gee, that sounds
very uncomfortable.
But "How, or where do you guys recommend I
get started on developing for Android devices?"
Anirudh, how about you take this one.
[silence]
You're on mute, Anirudh.
[laughs]
>>Anirudh: Alright.
So, we have plenty of documentation and a
lot of resources on developer.Android.com.
You can go there.
We have some Android U classes that give you
basics.
And just a lot of stuff on what Android is.
And the framework components on your own time
. And the entire library is available to you.
So I think just going to developer.Android.com
is a good start.
Also we have plenty of videos on YouTube and
there are a lot of resources around.
Which you can check out.
I see, I think that will be a good place to
start.
That would be our developer site.
>>Tony: Yeah, adding to that, I think in terms
of designing Android style application, we
have under developer.Android.com, we have
a specific session called slash design.
So it has tons of information about how to
design an app with the Android style application
as well.
So make sure you check that out.
In terms of online resource, stackoverflow.
There are a lot of questions answered.
Android questions get answered there.
So you hopefully can find a lot of answers
from stackoverflow as well.
>>Ankur: Yeah, look, I just shared the entry
point for our developer.Android.com training
site.
And you know, over there we literally show
you how to build your apps from the ground
up.
So you know, the only step that you need to
take prior to this is setting up your development
environment.
And again, if you go to the "tools" section,
you'll find it there.
And you need some familiarity with Java.
The rest of it, the Android side of it, is
you can learn about from this page here.
So this is the place where I recommend everyone
goes to basically start learning.
OK.
Now we have Hemmon on the Hangout here.
Hemmon, have you got access to a mic?
[silence]
No, OK.
So he's chatting and he's asking us some questions
about "Is there an easy way for remote debugging?"
and it looks like Anirudh has been working
with him, so Anirudh, do you wanna just walk
us through the question and the answer?
>>Anirudh: So the question is, and I'm still
trying to understand what's the involvement
that Hemmon has there.
So from what I can gather, he has a Linux
box.
And the device is available over the internet.
So was explaining, there is DDMS and ADB.
These are some of the tools that help you
connect to devices.
And ADB can work over S-search with call forwarding.
That's one way to develop a remote device.
So you may have your device attached to a
uh, laptop near you.
And your call base lives, or your APK lives
in a different machine.
And you can use ADB or S-search to deploy
remotely or debut.
There is also ADB or TCP which allows you
to connect to a device over the same subnet.
And ADB or TCP I think requires you to plug
in the cable first, and then say ADB mode
is TCP.
And then you can plug the cable out.
And then use the IP address to connect.
And if there are, if there is something you
wanna try about your environment, please go
ahead and we can also base on that.
>>Ankur: Yeah, very cool.
So he said, "It's clear."
OK, that's fantastic.
Next question.
"What is your stand on native versus HTML
5 apps?"
Again from Hemmon live.
Tony would you like to take this one?
>>Tony: I guess we really, it really depends
on your applications.
Like, what kind of features you need for your
particular application.
So the strength of like native apps is they
have a tighter integration access to sensors
in your phone.
And which, HTML5 is catching up.
But I think it's still like native apps can
do a better job internal accessing.
Like different sensor on your phone.
If that's what you need, in your particular
application, probably you may want to consider
more on native apps.
But HTML5 avocation of the benefit is, you
can reuse what you develop already, or call
for your, for desktop applications.
So you can use, we use a lot of the web stuff
you have already, through web view.
So I guess it really depends on your environment.
Or what you already have and what kind of
features you are planning to add to your application.
>>Ankur: Yeah, I might just add on that, that,
um, there is no one size fits all.
So when you ask this sort of question, I can't
say that it's very clear cut that you should
go one way or another.
Depends what's important to you.
Depends what you can put your priorities on.
Certainly native apps will tend to be very
responsive.
They'll tend to be faster.
I mean, typical web technologies tend to refresh
the whole page.
And that sort of thing.
So you can certainly put the work into your
web app.
To make it give a native experience.
Or at least give an experience that the user
is, feels is native.
But it depends where you can commit those
resources.
>>Tony: Yeah, I guess another key thing is
like, make sure you have an Android style
app.
I mean, doesn't matter what technology you're
using.
Make sure the user experience have a good
Android user experience.
I think that's also very important.
>>Ankur: Yeah, so I guess Tony, what you're
referring to are things like the action bar.
Better uses of the back button.
And those sorts of things that really give
it an Android look and feel.
>>Tony: Yeah.
Even the choice of graphics.
Like icons.
Like, we have our own style of buttons and
things.
So make sure you, you build an Android style
application in our platform.
>>Ankur: Yeah.
Cool.
Alright.
Thank you.
So, final question on the Moderator.
Is, "How do I take a picture of the content
of the webview completely?"
And he's posted a, well, it could be a she.
They've posted a link to a stackoverflow page
which is about programatically taking the
screenshot of a webview.
When that webview is rendering some flash
content.
And what the stackoverflow thread said was
that it, they were getting effectively black
boxes where the flash content lived.
I actually don't know of a way to do this.
I don't know if Anirudh or Tony know how to
do this.
But I don't know of a way to capture that
flash content when you take a screenshot.
>>Anirudh: Yeah, I have no clue either.
>>Tony: No.
>>Ankur: yeah, sorry about that.
Flash is one of those specialized pieces of
technology and I suspect that you know, through
various optimizations it's rendering in ways
that might make it harder for you to be able
to grab these screenshots.
I would suggest have a look at what happens
when you do it through DDMS.
You know, through the Eclipse tools.
If you can get away with that, then that might
be the solution you're looking for.
It's certainly not programmatic there, thought.
Um, now Hemmon wants to start a flame war
about whether HTML5 is gonna beat flash out
in the long term.
I think we try to avoid controversial topics,
Hemmon, so, it's a matter of opinion.
Who knows?
Um, I'm just going to go back and check if
there are any more questions that have been
posted on the event.
Doesn't look like it though.
So is there anyone else that's live that would,
that has any questions?
[pause]
No?
Alright.
Well, in that case, it's a fairly short one
today.
Thanks for joining us.
Thanks for tuning in.
we'll be back again next time.
Next week.
Same time.
And we look forward to seeing you then.
We'll obviously post the Moderator link beforehand.
So make sure you get those questions in.
We had some interesting questions today.
Some fairly technical ones.
So keep them coming.
And on that note, thank you very much.
See you later.
>>Anirudh: See you.
>>Tony: Thank you.
>>Ankur: Bye.
>>Tony: Bye.